le Kremlin ton père après l'annonce de
l'Élysée sur une possible rencontre
entre Joe Biden et Vladimir Poutine
dialogue se poursuivent mais parler de
plan concret d'organisation de sommeil
prématuré pour la Russie et précision de
notre correspondante à Moscou
seront réglées rapidement indique escort
parole du président russe mais pour
l'instant les autorités russes ne
confirme pas les informations de
l'Élysée sur l'organisation d'un Sommet
sur la sécurité en Europe le 24 février
je vous propose d'écouter
nous avons déjà envoyé des messages
indiquant qu'aujourd'hui à 1h du matin
environ il y avait eu un deuxième
entretien téléphonique avec le président
Macron
cette conversation téléphonique est-elle
initiative de Macron lui-même il est
clair que les tensions augmentent et que
des contacts activent se poursuivent
le dialogue au niveau des ministères des
Affaires étrangères ainsi que des
conseillers politiques
une réunion est possible
il existe maintenant une compréhension
claire et concrète concernant la
nécessité de poursuivre le dialogue au
niveau ministériel
un communiqué à l'issue de la deuxième
conversation téléphonique d'Emmanuel
Macron avec Vladimir Poutine dimanche
soir ainsi que des consultations avec
Joe Baden et Boris Johnson les Lisa
ainsi que la Maison Blanche précise
néanmoins que ce sommet au plus haut
niveau ne peut avoir lieu quand
l'absence d'une invasion russe de
l'Ukraine un entretien téléphonique
entre les chefs de diplomatie russe et
française est également prévu
aujourd'hui hier la porte-parole de la
diplomatie russe Marie Azza karova a mis
en garde contre les différentes
interprétations des échanges entre les
présidents russes et français et la
souligné que tous ceux sur quoi et de
parti se sont mises d'accord au cours
des contacts et
c'était prêt à avoir une conversation
téléphonique avec son homologue français
dimanche même mais que Jean-Yves Le
Drian n'était pas disponible